esbah leaders have met senior officials
from Palestinian groups Hamas and
Islamic Jihad to discuss the war with
Israel the group has also been holding
funerals for Fighters killed in
exchanges of artillery across the border
between Israel and Lebanon zor reports
from B yahon in southern
Lebanon it's been two weeks since
Hezbollah heeded the call of its Ally
the Palestinian group Hamas to join the
fight against Israel Hezbollah has been
taking casualties we are at the funeral
of one of its Fighters it's lost more
than 40 men in more than 2 weeks of
conflict along the border this time is
very different since the last war in
2006 between Hezbollah and the Israeli
Army this time around Hezbollah is on
the offensive and Hezbollah is treading
carefully it is launching attacks
against Israeli military positions from
open areas it is avoiding an Israeli
response that would Target population
centers which leaves them exposed at the
same time the Israeli drone surveillance
aircraft are in the Skies over the
Border area all day long now hasb says
that it is in the heart of this battle
it is not neutral but so far like I
mentioned the escalation along the
border is very limited to that region
hezbollah's Secretary General meeting
leaders from the Palestinian groups
Islamic Jihad and Hamas Hezbollah
releasing a photo but not saying when
that meeting took place
and clearly giving the message that
there is coordination between the groups
part of the socaled AIS of resistance
the biggest question is what will
Hezbollah do next it believes that by
its uh by targeting Israeli positions
along the border it is harassing the
Israeli Army it is keeping it busy
making it move divisions of the army to
the north um so that they will not put
more pressure on Hamas on the southern
front so the biggest question is will
Hezbollah join this fight further will
it will it use its long range um
missiles will it use its full military
capabilities at the moment no but at the
same time the Israelis are you know
threatening um Hezbollah that they will
face unimaginable Devastation if they do
Z
AL Southern
Lebanon let's see what more we might be
able to find out about this meeting
Elijah Magner is a military and
political analyst covering the Middle
East and North Africa you're joining us
from Brussels Elijah thank you for your
time today your thoughts on this meeting
Hezbollah Islamic Jihad Hamas What Might
Have Been discussed and what it
means well first of all hisbah Hamas and
the Islamic Jihad have an operation room
military operation room in Lebanon where
they coordinate since the beginning of
the war we talking about since the 7th
of O October and we have seen howah is
sometimes occasionally operating also
with the Palestinians On the Border
where the Palestinians have taken many
casualties there have been many
Palestinian militant crossing the
borders attacking the Israeli military
and the discussion between the leaders
is extremely important on two level the
military level is a coordination to what
is going on in Gaza and Hezbollah is
also acting as the eyes and the ears of
Hamas from the outside because hisbah
capability in drones communication and
electronic system offers a huge support
to Hamas inside Gaza and to the Islamic
Jihad secondly on the political aspect
there might be discussion
on slowing down the Israeli Invasion
because of the pressure the aess of the
resistance the involvement or potential
invol involvement of Iran the United
States and other countries and a wider
conflict there is a possibility of
coming up to a ceasefire all that is
negotiated among the political leaders
not the military inside Gaza this is why
these leaders need to meet and
coordinate their future action and in
case they conflict escalate where they
would go and what measures they would
take and what the size of their
involvement is going to be because
hisbah is already involved in the war
and has so far taken more or less 30 to
35 people who died in fighting Israel
and by the Israeli drones but as you say
Hezbollah already involved in this war
however everybody I've spoken to and
that includes our correspondent has
explained suggested that Hezbollah
doesn't want at this stage a fullscale
war with
Israel do we know do do you have any
read on what their red lines might be
red lines which if crossed would thrust
thrust them into a higher intensity
conflict with
Israel but the mean fact that hisbah has
attracted the tree out of nine Israeli
divisions splitting the Israeli forces
not allowing the Israeli to concentrate
only on Gaza and threatening Israel
about the possibility to engage on one
100 kilom bord between Lebanon and
Israel is already in involvement now
Israel is not realizing and it doesn't
guess if hisbah is going to attack from
the we West or from the east or from the
middle that's why they have evacuated an
indication that hisbah is giving to the
Israelis allowing them to
understand that the ground Invasion or
the ground attack on Gaza can trigger
further escalation where hisbah can
break the Border this is why the
Israelis have created two line of
defense taking very seriously the threat
that's coming from Hezbollah and
thinking that the Hezbollah Special
Forces who are several thousands deploy
along the borders that they might break
the borders and come in particularly
when hisbah blind the Israelis by
destroying all the camarads and The
Radars so how long hisbah can go I don't
think hisbah is going to go on an all
out War because there is an idea
trotting now that Israel is standing
down on a general invasion of Gaza
because doesn't want to be further
involved in going to a cemetery and a
trap that is waiting inside the city
Elijah Magner military and political
analyst on the Middle East thank you
very much for joining us